[موسيقى]
واحيانا احنا بنتمشى بشوارع الدوحه لما ما
يكون في مباريات تلتقي بشخصيات ااا رياضيه
بس طريفه وبيعملوا اعمال نادره صلاح الدين
اتى من المغرب الى تركيا الى الدوحه على
ظهر دراجه وهو يسوق دراجته ليصل ليتابع
المونديال هنا في قطر صلاح الدين بدي
اسالك شو الاشياء اللي واجهتك كصعوبات في
الطريق من بلدك المغرب الى هنا الى الدوحه
الصراحه كانوا كثير من الصعوبات كان طارق
جميل ومميزه صراحه لكن كان فيها اكثر من
الصعوبات صعوبات طبيعيه وصعوبات همم يعني
جسديه والحمد لله يعني كل شيء مستعد
واستطعت ان اتزوجها مثل بعد صعوبات هو
اصابته بمرض جفاف اليدين صعب بصراحه
لكن الحمد لله يعني همم همم كم مره نقول
يعني هذا شو كنت متعود ليه وعارفه وقديت
نجوز والحمد لله
انت خلقت معك الرحله من الدار البيضاء الى
تركيا ومن تم من تركيا الى الدوحه كما قلت
انا رحلتي ابتدات من تركيا انطلقت من
الدار البيضاء الى تركيا بالطائره لانني
كنت همم ما اقدرش احصل على الفيزا
لامور عبر اوروبا وما كنت يعني قد يعني
همم وجدت الراي في الاول لكن الحمد لله
بعد شهر ثمانيه
اشهر ونصف ثلاثه اشهر ونصف الشهر
هذا ايام كثيره بس شو الصعوبات عاده لما
تقطع هيك حدود خصوصا بين الحدود واتوقع
تركيا السوريه
لمده خمسه ايام لكي امر لك للاسف يعني
ما كان عندي حل الان ادخل من كل الحدودي
في الشمال ولا او احد يعني يستطيع الدخول
منه فالضطر اسالنا ارجع الى همم عاصمه
انقره واخذ طائره يعني مثل جميع الرحاله
اللي مروا كلهم اخذ طائره او باخره
لحظه بس هي رحله طويله من الحدود التركيه
السوريه الى ام الى انقره مسافتك
كلها دوله اخرى تركيا
قريبا اكثر من شهر وانا فقط اقطع المسافه
في تركيا
بعدين
قطعت الحدود شو صار معك بعدين كيف كانت
الخط الطريق عشان توصل للدوحه اخذت ذهبت
الى عمان من انقره ومن انقره جلسه في
الاردن تقريبا مده شهر في الاردن يعني كل
الاردن صراحه دوله جميله جدا
[موسيقى]
المملكه العربيه السعوديه للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه اللي كانت تجربه جديده بس يعني
مختلفه يعني قرب من الاردن الى يعني له
تقاليد خاصه لو بعد اشياء ليه الحمد لله
يعني همم
في الطريق كله يعني كان ترك صحراء كثير
يعني مثل الجنوب الاردن والحمد لله كانوا
صعوبه
الحمد لله وصلت الى ااا الدوحه قطر الخير
يعني وقطعه يومين من الحدود الى هنا وانا
الان يعني موديل سهره وانا استمتع
بالاجواء المونديال الصراحه اللي كل يوم
وكانني جديد كانني اعيش يوم جديد هنا هناك
سؤال يسال المشاهد صباح العربيه دائما لما
بتسافر هيك سفرات بتكون لحالك لوحدك
لما يكون هذا كنت في هالحاله يعني صراحه
لكن في الطريق يعني تلتقي معه الراس يعمل
معك ثلاث ايام اربع ايام
لمده 10 ايام من بعد او شديد وتلتقي مع
رجل اخر يعني يعني هناك كثير صعب يعني هذا
هو السفر يعني مش همم
مش محدده همم صراحه
كيفك يعني برده هلا الواحد يسافر لحاله
حلو بس هناك عقبات مثلا في مناطق نائيه
كيفكم بتلاقي مكان تنام فيه المبيت انا
كمان قلت لك انا وسافر لحالي فلدي جميع
المعدات لا بيت همم يعني انا من لحالي
انطب خيمشي لحالي يعني اطبخ لحالي يعني
جميع المودات اللازمه لكي همم امشي في اي
مكان الحمد لله ما دام همم وجود المياه
ممكن في الحياه اسمه ممكنه بالعربي
شكرا صلاح الدين مرحبا شكرا صباح العربيه